are you following me sort of you're not  from here  did central central intelligence approve  you  but central central intelligence I  wasn't talking to you what's wrong with  your eyes and her hair and her shape you  look like a frog no she doesn't  she has a great shape  not that it matters what shape you have  and if it did you're a great one it  doesn't everything matters every choice  matters there's no room for things that  don't matter or people that don't matter  goodness just looking at you messes we  perfect happiness that you're not happy  excuse me yeah well why we have three  clubs in your wheel it's the worst  caught on the deck means you're  uncertain in their beliefs  you're very observant little boy I know  fascinating  [Music]